take a look at this ball and his red
ball
look at him play with that ball he's
having so much fun probably more fun
than any bull has had in its life
he loves that ball go anywhere with it
it brings him so much joy so much joy
that ball and that bull together they're
inseparable look at him they just go
everywhere together no bull has ever
been it's ecstatic over a ball and it's
luck oh he punctured his ball the ball
has lost his butt look how sad he looks
look outside he's heartbroken hmm I
wonder I wonder how CNN feels about this
sad ball if the bull were Trump
or how does MSNBC feel about this sad
ball if he were Trump
[Applause]
with the New York Times feel about this
sad bull if it were Trump I'll be honest
I just wanted to use the tape of the
ball but it's true for the media to feel
good something must feel bad so for them
this week was like Christmas and Spring
Break combined the parents were out of
town in Hanoi which might they could
throw a kegger in DC and Michael Cohen
would be their stripper jumping out of a
cake into the arms and then prison true
to form that could sense his press sees
a gibbering rat as breaking news while a
process that might prevent nuclear war
that's a joke and boy did Bad News make
them feel so good she is leaving for a
second time without a substantive
nuclear agreement now he's running up
against sort of real world international
realities and he can't close the deal a
very rough and rocky 24 hours of the
president humbled back in Washington
humbled here in Hanoi heading back to
Washington empty-handed so first they
spend a week saying the president
president is going to give up too much
and then they wind what he didn't give
away a thing if I wasn't so high right
now I would say that they are biased now
look we we all want world peace but
walking away as part of negotiating but
the media sees just one moment as the
whole thing because they hate the guy
doing the deal now if you believe we
already gave up a lot just with a
meeting then we'll who needs dialogue at
all just bomb everyone why waste time
the downside yeah millions died but the
upside none of these pesky meetings with
people we don't like
it's weird so many pacifists rejecting
dialogue even when there's proof that
Trump's words actually did make the
world safer
do you remember Hawaii last year people
were freaking out as bureaucrats in
Hawaiian shirts we're trying to figure
out their computer password hint it's
I'm a jackass
but the meeting needed this North Korea
thing to fail because bad news is their
drug and the drug supply is low look at
the economy jobs peace it's pretty good
so the media willed North Korea to fail
they made it so that if Trump had
appeared to make any deal it would be
seen as a concession so did the media
actually work against world peace I mean
that's crazy right he makes a strong
case meanwhile the media saw Michael
Cohen at story shuffleboard a slimy tail
to knock the summit off the front page
and Cohen obliged delivering their drugs
the media drools over he is a racist he
is a con man and he is a cheat how
original I think Kathy Griffin has that
tattooed on her back but the media ate
it up and they crawled up Cohen's rear
like an intoxicated earwig we're seeing
a humbled Michael Cohen for this the
committee today allowed the anecdotes a
lot of the personal anecdotes have the
ring of truth and Michael Cohen's
closing statement where he said what he
fears for the country I was really proud
of this guy up there because he he's had
the world against him do you know why
he's proud of this guy these cheese
balls are actually close friends both
strike me as men who wear speedos to
breakfast
it's what a cheeseball does but since
Cohen offered no collusion the media was
left with real estate evaluation here's
the president's lawyers saying yeah we
inflated the assets in order to get
banks to do stuff for us holy crap the
rich guy he inflated assets that sounds
vaguely Kardashian thank you and I'll
take it I'll take it it's pathetic it
was a pathetic joke but I'll take it but
I feel for the media they need more
wrongdoing so here's three three bad
things three bad things Donald Trump did
that you should report on one Donald
Trump once laundered money yep he left a
20 in his suit when it went to the
cleaners - Donald Trump once shot a man
a dirty look for being rude to a nun at
church three Donald Trump once beat his
child at Yahtzee maybe those will soothe
the wounds of 2016 after all that's all
the news is these days drugs to reverse
the pain of an election no deal with kim
jeong-hoon take that 2016 Cohen calls
Trump erases take that 2016 but it's sad
Kavanaugh Covington smollett each one
was supposed to be that drug that would
make them feel better didn't work which
is why Cohen's hearing mattered so much
I fear that if he loses the election in
2020 that there will never be a peaceful
transition of power yeah well lucky for
you Cohen you'll be safe in prison
by the way by the way yeah I'll take it
by the way stormy Daniels actually sent
Cohen a note saying I'm proud of you at
least is she can be proud of something
that film Revenge of the I can tell you
it did not please her mother
I saw it three times it was disgusting
I'm gonna keep saying it cuz they got a
beep it all right so that hearing that
hearing was like a binge of greasy junk
food it goes in and it goes out and you
feel gross afterward but that's the
media's diet all bad no good
no roughage if only there were a drug
for that
do you find yourself rooting against the
country's best interests just because
you don't like the president he may try
to distract he may make a bad decision
with Kim jong-un because he's trying to
distract from Cohen's testimony this
can't be happening
North Korea's got nukes Trump's gonna
give away the store sounds like you want
this summit to fail you realize if it
does we're back to square one that's
exactly what I want doesn't everybody
maybe you should try Optimax what's that
it's a simple one add a pill that shoots
directly to the brain in seconds
instantly clearing your desires for
wanting something to fail the result
you're more willing to envision positive
outcomes for any situation even if you
don't like the person I've never met my
ex-wife's new boyfriend Chad but judging
from the picture she posts he just looks
like it but then I discovered Optimus
now I can see he does make her happy and
she's happy why should that bother me
thanks Optimus Thank You Chaz my
coworker Barbara got promoted instead of
me I would go to church every day pray
to God that única hit by a bus and I saw
that the company stock was up maybe she
did deserve that promotion it was more
qualified
thanks off to mix and thank you God for
not answering my prayers about Barbara
for so much will he go to sleep wow
they're wrong
eliminating a nuclear threat and ending
the Korean War that would be a good
thing
Thanks off to max you bet just remember
you shouldn't take it with coffee
so get Optimax today side effects
include clear vision grasping reality
and not being such a frickin buzzkill
nice
[Applause]